digging graves in st. Petersburg
Russia's second city for victims of
Kovac 19 a scene that's becoming more
common on Tuesday the country reported
the highest number of new coronavirus
cases in Europe and now there are
disturbing questions over health workers
who've raised the alarm about their
working conditions after gym yes I've
got a kinetic solid Alexandra this video
on Twitter shows dr. Alexander Shula
Poff on the left and a colleague who's
explaining how Shula puffs had been
forced to keep working despite having
covered 19 the colleague had previously
criticized their hospital management for
protective gear shortages and was
questioned by police for allegedly
spreading fake news but another video
made three days later apparently at
their Hospital seems to show Shula paav
by now being treated for the virus
retracting their complaints I feel
alright my temperature is not rising my
disease is asymptomatic have a runny
nose otherwise all is well what we said
was said when we were high on emotions
on Saturday according to local state
television quoting health officials
Shula puff fell from a second-floor
window at the hospital he's now
reportedly in a critical condition in
intensive care after suffering skull
fractures the same sources say he's the
third Russian doctor to fall out of a
window in the space of ten days the two
others died all three incidents which
are being investigated by law
enforcement authorities have prompted
intense discussion in Russia about
whistleblowers in the Health System
everywhere we have a lot of problems
there are not enough hospitals there now
allow enough doctors we don't have
enough medicine we don't have enough
equipment across Russia the number of
recorded copied 19 cases stands at more
than 155 thousand and officially the
disease has killed almost 1500 people
Moscow remains the country's worst hit
region accounting for more than a half
of new cases and here ninety percent of
patients are younger than 65 several
cities remain on lockdown
and while much of Europe looks to ease
restrictions the Russian government says
they'll stay in place until there's a
vaccine nadine barber al jazeera